plus I know you're being diplomatic but
I want to ask a guy like you okay to see
if you open up and kind of say this a
little bit or not in your eyes okay this
is your world from your POV top five
greatest of all time Fighters don't
forget about you can put Pride you can
put Bellator you can put UFC you can put
anything who do you put as top five
um which Gracie needs to be in it you
know I don't look at the last fights
what he did for MMA uh sakuraba beating
four Graces he should be in it Federal
milianenko he should be in it Ronda
Rousey should be in really Ronda Rousey
because she changed the world game
changer she was the one that you know so
all these things where they say talk
about the Mount Rushmore it's a very
hard to enjoy I mean Habib they're such
a freak athlete right now and they're
all good everywhere like with me I was
just good on the ground and standing and
I had a boatload of stamina but now
everybody has that and they're way
better wrestlers than I was so the the
level is much higher you're not putting
yourself in the top five no no listen
and I always say and they say top
hundreds I always say this and I mean
this from the bottom of my heart if I'm
in the top thousand I'm a very happy man
because we got what 7.8 billion people
on the planet I'll take those
is there anyone you enjoy watching like
you know like you say did you watch the
dust on fighting against Michael
Chandler like no I was on a flight is
there anyone who you're like I'm not
missing that guy fighting well that you
just mentioned that two guys you know no
John Jones but also gentler always
action Poirier always action you know
you have uh um Tony Ferguson always the
guys who always put it on the line and
who don't mind to get knocked out or win
by knocking so you must like Diaz as
well yeah because they just go and they
bring it you know the worst thing from a
fighter what I believe you know because
I had a lot of guys who were really good
and they wouldn't pull the trigger and I
know that they can win I know that but
they hold him back they're holding back
they're holding back and if you come out
of a fight and you're not tired and you
and you lost the fight to go that's on
you you know but if you give everything
that you have and then you lose at least
you know where you are you see because I
gave it my all it's time to go back to
the drawing more than just start trading
so what all the craziness taking place I
believe future looks right if you
believe future looks bright get your
latest Future looks bright hat of
valuetainment it says future looks
bright here future looks bright here we
got them in white we got them in Black
we got them in red or black on black
sold out these are about to sell out if
you haven't ordered one yet we had a
person in Michigan but one then he
bought three then when those three
people weren't in the office they had to
order 58 of them because people wanted
the future looks bright hat especially
during times like this because ain't
nobody saying future looks Pride toward
your future looks bright hat click over
here and to watch the entire podcast
click here take care everybody
foreign
[Music]